CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BATES BACKER FOR JUST
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTESE DALLY
DODD. AWESOME EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROSS HERTZBERG WESSEL
- TANTO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN WHAT CHOI BOGUE
HAND PORTANTINO ROCK. RUBIO
SKINNER KERN NUMBER WHITE HOUSE
WIENER WELL. CORMAN'S PRESENCE
MEMBERS TO GET YOUR ATTENTION OR
A WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
ON THE REAL THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY CENTER COVER GYRO AND
AFTER THAT LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY CENTER ROTH. AS WE
PREPARE FOR EASTER AND PASSOVER.
LET US PRAY THE PRAYER OF HOWARD
THURMAN AND ENDEAVORED TO BRING
PEACE TO OUR HEARTS AND OUR
WORLD. LORD MY GOD OPEN AND TO
ME LIGHT FOR MY BLINDNESS
COURAGE FOR MY FEAR HOPE FOR MY
DESPAIR AND PEACE FOR MY
TURMOIL. OPEN UNTO ME JOY FOR MY
SORROW STRENGTH FOR MY WEAKNESS
WISDOM FOR MY CONFUSION AND
FORGIVENESS FOR MY SEN. LORD
OPEN UNTO ME TENDERNESS FOR THE
TOUGHNESS LARA FOR MY HATES.
MYSELF FOR MYSELF. LORD LORD
OPEN UNTO ME AMEN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF. THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
. MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE DEEMED READ. MESSAGE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS THIS IS A TIME
FOR MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. S. C. NINE MOVED TO THE
CONSIDERATIONS OF THE DAILY FILE
. THE SECOND READING FILE THAT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTEEN FORTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS ALTHOUGH TO
WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS TO SENATE JOINT
RESOLUTION FOURTEEN SENATE BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR ELEVEN THANK
THEM SECOND READING WILL BE
DEEMED READ. MOVING ONTO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS THAT
SENATOR BATES FILE ITEM NINETEEN
. YOU MISTER PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETEEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF SEASON DO MORRIS
AS DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING. PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE
WAS DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY
AND ADVOCACY FOR THE ALZHEIMER'S
ASSOCIATION. HE WAS APPROVED IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
THIRTIETH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. BEN SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES I BAKER I
PORCHES BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO
HYPERTENSIVE I DALY AYE DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. HI
GONZALEZ. GROSS I HERTZBERG AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA. HI
LIMÓN I MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ. MANY
I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN HI-
TELEVOTE HI PAM HI PORTANTINO HI
RALPH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI WHITE
HOUSE STEVE AYE WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN. FORTUS GONZALEZ MELENDEZ
FIVE WILK. PEYSER THIRTY SIX THE
NOSE ARE ZERO THE DEPARTMENT IS
CONFIRMED FILE ITEM TWENTY
CENTER BASE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
NICOLE ELLIOTT HAS DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL PRIOR TO THIS ROLE SHE
WAS SERVING AS THE GOVERNOR
SENIOR ADVISER ON CANNABIS AT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT SHE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
THIRTIETH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. IT IS CHRISTIAN DEBATE
CENTER WIENER I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT NICOLE ELLIOTT- I SEE
I'VE I'VE KNOWN AND WORKED WITH.
ON THE CELLULAR FOR ABOUT A
DECADE NOW SHE WAS- WORKING IN
SAN FRANCISCO CITY HALL IN THE
MAYOR'S OFFICE. WHEN I WAS ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- AS I
WORK WITH HER AND COLLABORATED
WITH HER AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AT
THE STATE LEVEL- SHE'S ONE OF
THE MOST AWFUL. PROFESSIONAL AND
PLEASANT PUBLIC SERVANTS I'VE
EVER WORKED WITH- AND- THIS IS A
VERY STRONG CHOICE BY THE
GOVERNOR AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
SENATE BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF MICELI IT IN THIS CRITICAL
POSITION- AS WE'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST. FIVE YEARS SINCE WE HAVE
LEGALIZED CANNABIS THE MANY
CHALLENGES THAT THE STATE AS
WELL AS THOSE NATIONS I HAD AN-
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH MICELI
IT OVER THE LAST FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS AND SHE'S. CLEARLY
KNOWLEDGEABLE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY SHE'S OPEN TO
LEARNING WHAT SHE DOESN'T KNOW
AND HELPING TO GROW- THIS
INDUSTRY SO I'M EXCITED ABOUT
THIS APPOINTMENT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH. SIXTEEN
OR THE MICROPHONE SET UP A
CENTER BATES WITH A CLOSE. YES
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BAKER I PORCHES
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO HI
CORTESE AYE DALLY. DODD HI THERE
AWESOME I EGGMAN. HI PLEASE SIR
HI GONZALEZ GROSS. FIVE
HERTZBERG HI WESTERN HI HER TADO
I JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI THE MON HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MANY I NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN BY A CHIRLA VOTE HI PAM
I PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN. STERN I
NUMBER HI FOR CASKEY I WIENER I
WILK. THE PRESCRIPTION MEMBERS.
ALLEN FOR JUST DALLY. GONZALEZ
GROSS. SORRY JONES. FIVE
MELENDEZ WILK. EYES ARE THIRTY
FOR THE NOSE REVERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED SENATE
RATES FILE ITEM TWENTY ONE THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY ONE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DENNIS ALL
THEORY TO THE HORSE RACING BOARD
MR ALL THEORY HAS BEEN MANAGING
MEMBER OF THE MISSION REAL REAL
ESTATE GROUP SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HE HAS SERVED ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE WAS
APPROVED IN THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON MARCH THIRTY EFFORT TO
UNANIMOUS VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. I SEEN A
MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
COURTESY AYE TALLY AYE DODD. HI
THERE AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER I GONZALEZ GROVE I
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE HURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA AYE LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE
AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN
AYE. NIELSEN AYE TELEVOTE AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN HI I'M
BURKE AYE BY CAL SKI I WIENER
AYE WILK. PORTERS. FIVE THANK
YOU FOR MINOR PLEASE TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR
THANK YOU BUT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. GONZALEZ
WILK. FIVE OR THIRTY SEVEN. THE
END KNOWS ARE ZERO THE POINT IS
CONFIRMED THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MOVING ON TO THE THIRD READING.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU PREPARED.
HIS MEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION ELEVEN
BY SENATOR SKINNER RELATIVE TO
THE SOCIAL SECURITY TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED ACT A SACRED TRUST.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I'M PRESENTING
RESOLUTION S. J. R. ELEVEN
WHICH- ASKS CONGRESS TO MAKE THE
APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR
SOCIAL SECURITY SYSTEM SO THAT
IT'S FUNDING IS STABILIZED. NOW
BEYOND RETIREES AND I THINK ALL
OF US APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW
AT A CERTAIN AGE YOU ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR SOCIAL SECURITY IF
YOU'VE BEEN PAYING INTO IT.
SOCIAL SECURITY IS A KEY SOURCE
OF INCOME FOR VETERANS FOR
PEOPLE WHOSE SPOUSE MAY HAVE
DECEASED. CHILDREN AND THOSE
LIVING WITH DISABILITIES.
CRUCIALLY SOCIAL SECURITY
SURVIVOR BENEFITS PROVIDE INCOME
FOR MANY CHILDREN WHOSE PARENTS
DIED FROM CARBON. NOW THE
CURRENT FISCAL HEALTH OF OUR
SOCIAL SECURITY SYSTEM IS NOT
GOOD AND THAT IS BECAUSE IT IS
NOT BEEN ADJUSTED THE- EITHER
THE- EXPECTING WHAT IS PROVIDED
IF YOU ARE A BENEFICIARY OF
SOCIAL SECURITY OR- THE SOURCE
OF FUNDING. THAT CONTRIBUTES TO
IT. AND GOODS PROJECTED THAT BY
TWENTY THIRTY FOR. THE SOCIAL
SECURITY SYSTEM WILL FACE A 20%
SHORTFALL NOW MANY OF US HERE ON
THIS FLOOR NOT HAVING PENSIONS.
MAY LIKE MANY MANY MANY MANY
AMERICANS RELY ON SOCIAL
SECURITY IS OUR SOLE SOURCE OF
INCOME WHEN WE RETIRE. AND MANY
OF US WILL BE AT THAT RETIRING
AGE AROUND TWENTY THIRTY FOUR.
DO WE WANT TO HAVE 20% OF
WHATEVER IS PROJECTED TO BE
COMING IN OUR SOCIAL SECURITY
CHECK TO NOT BE THERE. AS CHAIR
ELEVEN CALLS ON CONGRESS TO PASS
HOUSE RESOLUTION FIVE SEVEN
TWENTY THREE WHICH WOULD UPDATE
AND EXPAND SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS. AND ALLOW FOR THOSE
WAGE EARNERS WHO GET INCOMES OF
ABOVE A HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND THAT'S AN INDIVIDUAL
WAGE EARNER. TO CONTRIBUTE INTO
SOCIAL SECURITY BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW IT'S CAPPED AT THAT AMOUNT.
AND IF IT WERE OPEN TO THERE
THEN WE WOULD DEAL WITH THE
SHORTFALL SO IT COULD STABILIZE
ITS FUNDING AND- WITH THAT
ASPIRO VOTE. THANK YOU MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
DOLLING. THANK YOU ADAM TERMS I
JUST READ RISE TO A COMMENT
ABOUT. YOU KNOW SO SECURITY IN
THOSE ARE ON FIXED INCOMES IN
THOSE WAGE EARNERS THAT ARE-
HOURLY WAGE EARNERS THE REAL
BURDEN ON THOSE FOLKS TODAY IS
THE INFLATION WHICH IS RISING AT
IN SOME CASES 7% A MONTH. IF YOU
REALLY WANT TO HELP THOSE FOLKS
ARE ON THOSE FIXED INCOMES AN
HOURLY WAGES WE NEED TO DRIVE
DOWN THE COST OF LIVING HOUSING
THE COST OF ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA
WE'VE WE'VE SPENT ALMOST 60%
MORE ON ENERGY WE ALSO HAVE THE
HIGHEST TAX RATE ON FUEL- AND
FOR TRANSPORTATION NEEDS THOSE
THOSE WILL IMPACT THESE. UP
PEOPLE QUICKER IN IF IN A FASTER
MANNER THAN GOING TO THE PROCESS
OF GETTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO DO ANYTHING ON
SOCIAL SECURITY OR THE LIKE SO I
JUST WANT TO RISE AND SAY LOOK
IF WE REALLY IS CALIFORNIANS
WANT TO HELP- THESE FOLKS IN OUR
STATE WE NEED TO DRIVE DOWN THE
COST OF LIVING. IMMEDIATELY
THIRTY LEYVA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO STAND
IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF S. G.
R. ELEVEN IT WAS A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO WHEN I FOUND OUT THAT
YOU DIDN'T PAY INTO SOCIAL
SECURITY ON EVERY DOLLAR THAT
YOU EARNED AND IT'S JUST
OUTRAGEOUS IMAGINE THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT MAKE MORE
THAN A HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR THE PAY
INTO IT EVERY MONTH WHAT HAPPENS
IS WHEN THEY HIT THAT CAP DEPEND
ON HOW MUCH YOU MAKE IT COULD BE
JUNE JULY COULD BE DECEMBER THEN
THEY GET MORE MONEY IN THEIR
PAYCHECK BECAUSE IT'S NOT BEING.
TAKEN OUT THIS IS SUCH AN EASY
FIX TO MAKE SURE THAT SOCIAL
SECURITY IS WELL FUNDED IF WE
DID THIS I READ AN ARTICLE WHILE
BACK IF WE DID THIS WE WOULD
ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO INCREASE
WHAT OUR SENIORS GET WE CAN
INCREASE SOCIAL SECURITY THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE
HARD IN THE LEGISLATURE IN
CONGRESS THIS IS EASY AND IT
WILL HELP OUR EOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY THE MOST WHICH
IS OUR SENIORS SO I STRONGLY
SUPPORT- AS YOUR ELEVEN AND I
HOPE THAT WHEN THEY GET IT.
SENATORS KINNER THEY WILL TAKE
NOTE AND DO THE RIGHT THING
THANK YOU MEMBERS. THURSDAY I
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE- THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I THINK WE'VE HAD A
GOOD DISCUSSION AND WITHOUT AYE
OSCAR AYE VOTE. M. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BAKER I PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE
A HI FOR AYE DOLLY. GOD. FIVE
ZERO SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN. I GLAZER
I GONZALEZ GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE
WESSEL AYE HURTADO AYE JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMON AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN- CHAU
BOTH. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
HI I'M BURKE HI WE CASKEY FIVE
WINNER. I WILK. BECAUSE THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN BATES.
PORGES DALLYING. GONZALEZ GROVE
JONES MELENDEZ NIELSEN WELL CHOI
BOGUE WELL. HIGHS ARE TWENTY
NINE NEW ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
FOUR CENTER DIED. BE PREPARED.
AND SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
TRIBAL GAMING AND ACQUIRING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SIX FIFTY
MEALING. THIS PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
SB THREE OH TWO RATIFIES
AMENDMENTS TO THE TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IN THE CAMPO BAND THE
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA. THE SANTA
ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY AND TABLE
MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA THE AMENDMENT
SIMPLY EXTEND THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY NINE COMPACTS WHICH ARE
SET TO EXPIRE AT THE END OF
JUNE. BY ONE ADDITIONAL YEAR.
THE THIS A LOT WILL ALLOW
NEGOTIATIONS ON THE TRIBE'S NEW
COMPACTS TO CONTINUE. THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ANY
OBJECTIONS. DOING YOUR THAN
THIRTY THE- ISER THIRTY SEVEN
TWO DOES YOUR ON THE URGENCY
ISER THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS YOU'RE
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WOULD THERE BE ANY
MEMBERS ONE REMOVE SOMETHING FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. C. NINE
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
BOTH CONSENT CALENDARS. SENATE
BILL 935-956-1005 NINE TEN TEN
OF SEVEN FOURTEEN FORTY ONE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS. 1-191-409-1551 FIFTY SIX ONE
FIFTY AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY. THANK YOU
MAY YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
A FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE. ALLEN
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BACKER AYE FORTUS AYE
BRADFORD I CABALLERO HI
PROTESTING AYE DALLY. I DON.
FIVE ZERO SEVEN FIVE EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ ROVE. I
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER. AYE
LAYERED AYE LEYVA. I LIMÓN HI
MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN I PATROL BOAT I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI KELSEY I WIENER AYE
WILK. HELLO SIZER THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ARE ZERO CONSENT COUNTERS
ARE TOPPED AND MOVING ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS CENTER
CABALLERO. MISTER MISTER
PRESIDENT- BE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE WILL MEET. THE
MINUTES AFTER OUR ADJOURNMENT IN
THE- STREET BUILDING ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. THANK YOU.
RETURNING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
NOW'S THE TIME FOR JOURNEY
MEMORIES. SENATOR DODD. FOR
JOINING MEMORY GIVEN YOUR NUMBER
TO. PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
CONGRESSMAN VIC FAZIO WHO PASSED
AWAY ON MARCH SIXTEENTH AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTY NINE YEARS OLD.
CONGRESSMAN FAZIL WAS A LEADER
WHO LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK ON
YOLO COUNTY CALIFORNIA. YOLO
COUNTY CALIFORNIA IN OUR COUNTRY. HE REPRESENTED CALIFORNIA'S
CAPITAL REGION FROM NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE TO NINETEEN NINETY
NINE AND WAS A MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE APPROPRIATIONS IN ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE. HE ALSO
SERVED AS CHAIRMAN. OF THE
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE THE
PREVIOUSLY SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. DURING HIS CAREER FIVE
ZERO SUPPORTED ETHICS REFORMS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WATER
RECLAMATION PRIVATE PROGRAMS IN
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENTS
CONGRESSMAN FAZIL SECURED
FUNDING FOR PROJECTS LIKE THE
VAST WETLAND AND WILDLIFE
PRESERVE BETWEEN- KNOWN RIGHTLY
AS THE VICTOR FIVE ZERO YELLOW
WILDLIFE AREA. IT WAS DEDICATED
BY PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN. HERBERT
FIVE ZERO JUNIOR WAS BORN IN
WINCHESTER MASSACHUSETTS ON
OCTOBER ELEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY
TWO HE CAME TO CALIFORNIA ON A
CAR OF FOUNDATION FELLOWSHIP IN
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AND WORKED AS A
LEGISLATIVE CONSULTANT. HE WAS
ALSO A CO FOUNDER IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY OF THE FORMER CALIFORNIA
JOURNAL MAGAZINE WHICH IS A
MAINSTAY FOR DECADES IN THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY. HIS IME
ELECTED OFFICE HE MENTORED
COUNTLESS STAFF AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS ALL WHILE DELIVERING
RESULTS FOR HIS CONSTITUENTS AND
OUR ENTIRE STATE. AFTER DECIDING
NOT TO SEEK REELECTION IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT HE SPENT
MORE THAN TWO DECADES AS AN
ADVOCATE IN DC IT CAME BACK AS
BOARD CHAIRMAN OF THE NATIONAL
PARKS CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF THE
PREVENT CANCER FOUNDATION. HE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE KATHY
SAWYER WHO HE MARRIED TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AS WELL AS
DAUGHTER FROM HIS FIRST MARRIAGE
DATA FAWZI OO LAURIE OF GRANITE
BAY TWO STEP CHILDREN KEVIN AND
CHRISTIE KERN AND FOUR
GRANDDAUGHTERS KENDRA CARLY HERE
A AND P. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING IN THE MEMORY OF THAT
POLICY. THANK YOU. CENTER PATH.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT CENTERS I
TO- WANT TO JOIN- MY GOOD FRIEND
FROM- NAPA IN A JOURNEY IN
MEMORY OF CONGRESSMAN- VIC-
RIVAZ ZERO. WHO PASSED AWAY ON
MARCH SIXTEENTH- AT AGE SEVENTY
NINE AFTER A BATTLE WITH
MELANOMA. AS MENTIONED HE SERVED
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE DSL AND
THEN THE U. S. HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES THE ALSO SERVES
LOCALLY HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY IS A MEMBER TO SACRAMENTO
COUNTY PLANNING COMMISSION. AND
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY CHARTER
COMMISSION. I WAS INVOLVED KNOWN
FOR HIS ABILITY TO WORK ACROSS
THE AISLE AND HE'S BEEN IN AND
HE'S DONE TREMENDOUS WORK FOR.
BALLINA COMMUNITY BUT ALSO FOR
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND IS MENTIONED
THAT TO ESTABLISH THE- VIC FAZIO
YELLOW WILDLIFE AREA THAT
ACTUALLY BORDERS BETWEEN. WEALTH
AND- A GOOD FRIENDS DISTRICT BUT
BORDERS MY DISTRICT AS WELL SO-
WITH THAT AGAIN SEE SOMEONE WHO
IS- BEEN REVERED AND- THIS TO ME
I REPRESENT AND I ASK THAT WE
ALSO INTERNET IS MEMBERS THANK
YOU. NIELSEN MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I HAVE
HAD AN INTERESTING. WITH
CONGRESSMAN FACIO I WAS THE
CHAIRMAN OF HIS OPPONENT
CAMPAIGN IN YOUR COUNTY WHEN
THEY FIRST RAN. WEEDED OUT ALL
THAT AGAINST EACH OTHER I FOUND
IT TO BE A THOROUGHLY COMPETENT
. AMICABLE DEAR FRIEND. MOST
IMPORTANTLY BIG TENDED TO THE
HOME PERSON TURRIFF. A GOOD
CITIZENS CONSTITUENTS
CONGRESSMAN AND BEFORE THAT
ASSEMBLY EROSION LEADERSHIP IN
HIS OWN PARTY IN CONGRESS.
THAT'S A TOUGH THING TO DO. YOU
HAVE TO BE VERY CREDIBLE. AND
VERY HARD WORKING AND VERY
DEDICATED. HE DID THAT WHILE
ATTENDING TO THE HOME FRONT AS
WELL IN THIS CASE I DO NOT MEAN
IS CONSTITUENTS I MEAN HIS
IMMEDIATE FAMILY. FACIO THE
THOROUGHLY GOOD MAN WE WILL MISS
HIM. THEN I WILL HONOR HIM IN MY
PRAYERS. SENATE DOT PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME UP CERTAINLY PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS INTERACTIONS THE
DESK IT'S CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT
THANKS SO MUCH I COLLEAGUES I
WISH TO US SAFE TRAVELS HOME TO
YOUR DISTRICT FOR A WEEK WHERE
YOU CAN FOCUS ON YOUR
CONSTITUENTS AND SPEND QUALITY
TIME WITH YOUR FAMILIES. AND
WITH THAT- SAFE TRAVELS OUR NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY APRIL EIGHTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THE
SENATE WILL BE RECESSED- THREE
THIRTY WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE MADE THE
RECONVENE MONDAY APRIL
EIGHTEENTH AT TWO PM ENJOY YOUR
WEEK SEE THAT.